good afternoon everyone my name is dr
miller and the scp we're going to be
looking at today
is scp-1370
object class
safe
special containment procedures
scp-13
is locked in a fireproof glass display
case stored in gallery 27. if the case
becomes damaged by external circumstance
any container with the dimensions of at
least 1.25 by 0.75
by 0.50 meters will suffice as a
replacement until a new display case is
available the ethics committee
recommends that any long-term storage
case contain enough space for
scp-1370 to move freely level 2
personnel in higher may remove
scp-1370 from its case at their
discretion but will face disciplinary
action for failing to secure it properly
afterward
description
scp-1370 is a self-aware artificial
being constructed from various
electrical devices and tools it stands
approximately one meter in height and is
capable of moving its articulated joints
despite any lack of power source or
motors
scp-1370 communicates in a monotone
voice by a speaker mounted in its chest
its head is a voltmeter soldered upside
down to a neck joint giving the
appearance of a friendly smile but
containing no active sensory devices
however
scp-1370 will react to visual and
audible stimuli and its ability to do so
is hampered when the head is covered or
otherwise restrained its design appears
to give more importance to aesthetic
concern rather than function as
evidenced by poor center of gravity that
hampers its ability to balance and walk
it is therefore believed that scp-1370
was created as an art object and later
imbued with anomalous properties rather
than designed with those in mind
it can currently speak fluent american
english french and latin and is capable
of learning new languages other facets
of its intellectual capacity have not
been clearly outlined as
scp-1370 is invariably hostile in all
interactions with any being or object it
interprets to be sapient this includes
but is not limited to animals foundation
personnel civilians audio visual
equipment and security cameras
if scp-1370 encounters an object that
believes to be sapient it will attempt
to engage the object in combat while
introducing itself with a variety of
elaborate titles which appear to be
selected at random examples include
doombot 2000 robo-lord the destructor
prime minister sinister and darth claw
killflex
scp-1370 will often include variations
to these titles based on responses it
receives from personnel foundation staff
have successfully introduced patheticon
the garglemost and pesterbot to its
lexicon
addendum many tests on scp-1370's combat
prowess have been run each confirming
that scp-1370 lacks the physical
aptitude to cause damage to any living
being test 1370 8239 exposed scp-1370 to
a common house plant with a speaker
hidden in the plant's pot after scp-1370
was provoked verbally it attempted to
fold and twist the leaves of the plant
within its grasp before incapacitating
itself
the log of this event follows
researchers l allens and t bossum carry
scp-1370's case into the testing chamber
the case is set down one meter from a
potted philodendron fitted with a small
speaker 1370.
[Music]
researchers leave the testing chamber
and the cases opened remotely although
no security risk is determined the test
requires
scp-1370 to focus on the plant rather
than the nearby personnel observations
are made via an opaque glass window to
prevent scp-1370
from attacking its own
[Music]
rent within reflection dentures all
shall be trampled beneath my feet high
and shivatron the spoiler of earth
hello can you hear
all
me
shall burn you will feel the sharp sting
of my wrath i identify yourself so that
i may stand damnation upon you as you
die
i'm a split
a semi philadelphia shrub with large
glossy leaves
these leaves could grow up to three feet
long
i have arrived you will be crushed
scp-1370 falls over and is unable to
write itself after approximately six
minutes it knocks the pot over which
rolls into a position that pins
scp-1370's body to the floor of the
chamber researchers enter to return
scp-1370 to its case
okay well there you have it the
legendary pesterbot everyone i thought
i'd give a little bit of a of a break
from the very serious and um real
anomalies we've been covering recently
and pesterbot seemed like a good change
of pace
anyway
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
the wall cranked with the first impact
with the second an enormous lizard burst
through it sending a glass display case
flying as it shrugged off the
copper-jacketed lead that impacted its
back almost negligently it turned around
and spat acid at the last of the team
desperately trying and failing to
contain it
they were no threat
a tinny high-pitched voice rang out in
the room
the lizard turned its attention from the
rapidly melting human towards the new
voice perplexed
[Music]
the lizard looked down to see where the
voice was coming from it was an odd
assortment of parts that looked vaguely
humanoid it seemed to be attempting to
pick itself up off the floor
the odd little robot finally got to its
feet and shook a wrench fist at it
[Music]
almost without thought the lizard lazily
brought its claw down on the irritating
little thing intent on crushing it at
the last moment the little robot lost
its balance awkwardly toppled over
backwards and rolled up against the wall
the bit of clumsiness had spared it from
the reptile's negligent strike
you cannot harm the inventor none can
defeat me
the lizard tilted its head to the side
oddly amused by the pathetic little
thing it took just a moment to indulge
in the novelty of the experience as the
creature teetered up to its claw and
latched on with one of its ridiculous
appendages
the reptilian lifted his claw to get a
closer look at the little thing that was
hanging onto it as the little automaton
strained with all its strength in vain
attempting to harm it
the little robot hung from the lizard's
claw for a moment before its grip gave
out and it fell tumbling to the floor
and rolling till it was upside down
so
you want to fight dirty do you castrate
and play at that game too
the lizard had tired of this thing it
was no longer amusing just irritating it
raised its claw to strike the thing down
in earnest not settling for a lazy
negligent strike that could miss at that
moment it was struck by a volley of
rockets and half a dozen simultaneous
explosions reducing it to a lump of
misshapen flesh
behind it the backup containment team
that had stealthily crept up while it
was being distracted by the hostile
robot lowered their shoulder-mounted
rocket launchers
all right let's get ugly here back to
containment i want it in the acid bath
yesterday don't give it a chance to
regenerate thompson take pesterbot here
to storage closet 8f until the egg gets
figure out something better to do with
it
oh for [ __ ] sake who taught it that
one
i would like to give a special thank you
to aletreon
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
your local fishman
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
octo potato football match
hms lily
the almighty fish
syodio dimnatus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you